well the latest ramping up of tensions
involves three other countries that
poland belarus and ukraine but the main
concern is that russia could be
preparing for an invasion of ukraine
well a key location is in yelnia that's
just 125 kilometers east of the border
with belarus and 230 kilometers north of
ukraine
satellite images purport to show russian
military units including tanks armoured
personnel vehicles and self-propelled
artillery
russia insists it's all part of a normal
training exercise to the south the u.s
and others have been concerned about
movement near the russian city of
voronez
around 160 kilometers from the border
with ukraine movement of military
hardware and troops at the poganova
training facility has been ongoing
again russia insisted this was due to a
large training exercise well the
heightened tensions come almost eight
years on from russia's annexation of
crimea
in nova zone in the yev pretoria region
80 miles from the ukrainian border
satellite imagery shows a buildup of
more military hardware
russia announced it would deploy a new
paratroop regiment to the region last
month
our moscow correspondent dianna magnay
has this report
hello
the stakes for this video call could not
be higher we didn't get to see one
another at the g20 i hope next time we
meet we do it in person the kremlin has
already warned that there won't be any
breakthroughs from this call but it's
also made clear where it wants to see
progress
on what's known as the minsk agreements
a set of measures long since stalled
that would see the war-torn separatist
republics in eastern ukraine receive a
degree of constitutional autonomy which
ukraine is reluctant to give
[Music]
monday was national army day in ukraine
a chance for president vladimir zelinsky
to show off some of the hardware that
nato has gifted his armed forces
red rags to a bull as far as russia is
concerned if vladimir putin does decide
to invade it's hard to see what he would
hope to achieve any intervention would
be extremely bloody the ukrainian forces
are far better equipped and more capable
than they were in 2014 or 2015 and
capturing and holding territory in a
country which is largely hostile to
russia would be very difficult
these men last met in june in geneva the
first time this year that russia had
mass troops on its border this time
round president putin has been much more
explicit about what his red lines are
not just ukraine one day joining nato
but the fact that nato is already so
involved in bolstering ukraine in its
fight with its neighbor to the east
he promised that he will defend the red
lines
you cannot repeat it
many times
being threatening
and then not to do something it's not
yet clear if these two hours of talks
have cooled this crisis whether the
threat of strong economic and other
measures is enough to deter russia that
is ultimately up to vladimir putin
the proof whether he starts to draw down
his troops or not
dana magnay sky news moscow